hello and welcome to energized a podcast
series from Intelligence Squared in
partnership with epidrola where we bring
together leading voices to discuss the
big issues within energy and the
environment I'm your host Kamal Ahmed
and today's topic the third in our
series on the role of energy networks in
the race 2 net zero this time the Grid
in the United States
the inflation reduction act signed in
August 2022 aims to cut greenhouse gas
emissions by 40 by 2030. in doing so it
represents America's largest ever
investment to fight climate change and
yet
clean energy projects in the US
currently face lengthy delays to even be
connected to the grid
and transmission capacity will need to
double over the next decade if
electricity emissions are to be cut by
half by 2030
it clearly is a messy picture and one
that reminds us as we have learned
throughout this energized series that
there can be no transition without
transmission
so what are the specific problems facing
the expansion of clean energy
Transmission in the US and how can we
fix them
to help answer these questions and more
I'm joined by Pedro azagler the CEO of
avongrid
Pedro welcome to energized good morning
I'd like to start at the beginning if
possible Pedro
just tell us about the state of the
current grid in the US and when it was
built and how it operates today how are
those U.S transmission lines broken up
good morning pleasure to be with you and
I hope we'll learn a little bit because
us we all know there are very
challenging Dynamics ahead of us
I think in terms of the current rate in
the U.S there are three parts in
discrete the eastern part the western
part and Texas almost non-communication
or connection among the three of them
and that is a Pity this network has been
built mainly in the 60s and the 70s
and I'm going to give some examples
about our current networks for example
in New York
20 25 of our poles are more than 60
years old
one-third to one-half of our circuit
breakers are at least 30 years old
that is your feeling how obsolete the
networks are right now and why because
the world was different 60 years ago and
the US was ahead of almost any country
in terms of electrification
networks generation Etc but there is a
moment it becomes Obsolete and that's
the reason why the U.S right now one of
them in issues as you very well said is
the absolute infrastructure that does
not allow for the transverse transfer of
energy as needed within the U.S Pedro is
so fascinating hearing those figures
that you just gave us what I'm Amazed by
looking at this issue is how
because maybe you can't see the national
power grid every day it's not like
getting on a train or seeing what a road
surface looks like it has been allowed
to deteriorate in this way would you put
that down to the fact that such an
important part of our infrastructure has
got to this position where so much of it
is either obsolete or is creaking on the
verge of obsolescence I think when you
look at the US everybody wants energy
more energy and more energy a home in
the factories everywhere when you look
right now at the climate change that we
are suffering we were commenting before
about July this year look at the weather
in the Northeast it normally doesn't
look like a summer
I think when you look at the climate
change the amount of hurricanes the
amount of tropical storms 5 10 20 times
more than 50 years ago
when you have more demand
more consumption of energy
when you have more issues in the weather
and you have a 50 60 80 year old
infrastructure
basically it does not work it cannot
cope with the needs that consumers have
ahead of them in terms of electricity
consumption
and what is the impact of this separated
Network system that you so clearly
explained on our journey and our efforts
to Electrify the economy which is such
an essential part of the decarbonization
journey
I like to use always third parties
comments and MIT which probably is one
of the top universities from an
engineering point of view in the world
they basically mentioned very clearly if
you're going to have in the U.S every
state on its own doing the
decarbonization of the grid versus the
whole country doing it you know for
everybody I think it's probably double
the cost of this decarbonization in the
grid to give some numbers one could be
135 dollars the other one could be 733
to 73 dollars that's the difference 135
versus 73 that's why transmission
congestions right now are on the rising
you have more than doubled you know
those issues more Renewables becoming
available more consumption all these
data centers you can continue and
continue that's why the combination of
that the federal approach the one
country approach versus the state HD it
would be the benefit of the customers so
let's unpick that little bit when we
think about the specifics what is the
way forward is it building
huge new continents continent spanning
uh power lines that can carry all this
enormous new demand that you've been uh
talking about or the supply to
um uh meet that demand or are we talking
about smaller upgrades local power lines
a much more local way of transmitting
power generated by wind or solar Farms
is it super big super big infrastructure
or is it smaller
networks that can help increase the pace
towards this decarbonized future
I think we need everything you know this
is like generation when people say it
only should be built this type of
generation well you know it's very
complicated to change you know a hundred
thousand megawatts in 24 hours into
something that we would love all to be
different when you think about
infrastructure related to transmission
of course company like ours we care
about the big numbers we care about the
big energy needs of course there are
also a small uh networks there are small
needs at the local level but we need to
focus on a much bigger picture
you think about the following numbers
right now in terms of additional
transmission just coming from transport
electrification and Home Heating is
probably three and seven billion a year
when you think about Bijon 2013 these
numbers up to 2050 probably is going to
multiply by two or three those are the
big numbers we have right now
when you think about the long distance
transmission lines think about the new
generation coming into operation ahead
of us usually it's not next to your home
usually it's not next to a big town a
big city so you need to bring that power
whenever it's produced to whatever is
consumed I think you have seen right now
the transfer of capacity between the
East and the West is increasing that's
probably you know some dollars of
savings for customers so the more we
interconnect the better
there are projects like the one we are
leading right now between Canada and
Massachusetts that basically focuses on
what focus on access to cheap other
Alternatives of energy in this case
hydropower coming from Canada and
finally you mentioned the local upgrades
for me local probably is a state level
okay maybe local means our homes
communities tones I think for us local
means at the state level the New York
City example you know we have to
reinforce our distribution networks
because if you put all the new
generation coming from Renewables with
existing Network
doesn't work simply the electricity
cannot flow in our case just in the case
of New York it's called clcpo clcpa
which is a legislation approving some
investments in short mission to allow
for that connection between renewable
energy and the consumption of energy
just in our case is 3 billion for the
next seven or eight years so any amount
you pick up for us for a state or the
country is billions and billions so it's
massive amount of money it's incredible
some of those challenges that you've
been outlining there but interesting to
see that there are Solutions as you say
the Canada Massachusetts work that
you're doing does give us some sense of
a possible road map Pedro take us
through
the unique challenges of America the
world's largest economy where America
goes so many other nations follow or
geographies follow what are the what are
the unique challenges posed by
electrification and decarbonization in
the US and the lessons that you are
already learning can they be exported
elsewhere
from an energy point of view it's very
interesting with you know chairman Galan
and the rest of us arrived in the U.S to
the business uh 15 more than 15 years
ago now I remember taking a presentation
about the importance of independence of
energy
well very few people paid attention 15
years ago we used to put example about
the national energy plan in Spain as
Spain was dependent on one gas pipeline
coming from one country
think about one gas pipeline coming from
another country at the mess you have in
Europe right now so you had us there and
in that case you know Spain building
different LED terminals around the
country just to make sure you could have
said that we're speaking about 15 years
ago I think today you look at
Massachusetts for example you look at
Connecticut right now we are concerned
about whether the winter is going to be
tough because we may not have enough gas
available to be put into the gas pipes
and basically take it to customers I
think we are concerned about any gas
pipeline development it's not the case
any longer for many years it's not
allowed to do if any gas pipeline
development so then we moved into what
we tried to do which is renewals and we
try to do officer win answer wind solar
I think you see how many times the first
thing that people are going to say main
issue is called permitting it takes a
lot of time so that's why my main area
of focus if you were to tell me there
risks you know what are the challenges
right now it's called permitting and can
we just unwrap that and unpack that a
little bit Pedro when you're talking
about permitting take us through
what some of the hurdles are through the
permitting process
very very simple let me just give you
two or three examples when you think
about an onshore wind park or onshore
solar facility I think we're speaking
probably you know knowledge on five
years to be able to get all the
permitting and then you think about the
construction of one two years
so add those two numbers
if you think about the lobster project
it's probably eight years of Permitting
to get it through and then you know you
can add two or three years to build
when you think about a transmission line
or speaking at least of 10 years
and this is just the permitting now
welcome to the world of litigation now
you have a lot of people that
potentially oppose many for a reason but
also many just because they want to make
sure that nothing new is built because
that may put in danger they're existing
Dynamic of the market where they make a
lot of money and they don't want any new
energy because that may bring prices
down or eats cheaper energy or green
energy they're happy to stay where they
are and nothing changes so when you see
those two dynamics that gives you
already the many many years that takes
to get anything done it's incredible
Pedro reading some of the detail and
listening to you that
the permitting process takes longer
than building the new network people
will be very surprised by that they
should
as we suffer they should I think you
think of you about Europe right now one
of the key things there is they struggle
right now with access to energy because
many times you know we are used to
basically pay very cheap here in the US
for energy for the car or electricity
for gas when you think about the prices
in other countries is two three four
five ten times more but they issue in
many situations as you're seeing right
now in Europe is not the cost is the
access to energy so from that point of
view when you have energy you don't
really value so much the energy is worth
we should start all thinking that energy
of scarce resource that is gonna cost
money because it's not easy to access
but also it's a Pity that having the
access to that energy permitting and
mitigation basically triggers massive
delays in in putting that energy
available to everybody let's have a look
at how the legislation has changed
because they have obviously been big
moves at the federal level in the US to
change the terms of trade in the path to
decarbonization what Pedro do you feel
the impact has been of President Biden's
the historic inflation reduction Act
on the work that uh Avan grid and you do
specifically I think the inflation act
and you know the investment and jobs Act
in our opinion is very good news first
because both parties agree and get
something done so the more we can work
together all of us and get things done
the better that's why for example when
you have seen the budget and some things
to make sure the debt ceiling you know
that you had to you know to go through
in terms of negotiation and the
permitting is put into that negotiation
that's good news let's continue having
the permitting as often as we can in any
negotiation because that means that's
moving when you think about the IRA more
than 500 billion committed through that
you think about Investments and jobs act
another more than 500 billion you think
about the tax credit Market being
created the 10 year of predictability
that's what investors long-term
commutative industrial investors like us
that's what we need to make sure there
is predictability ahead of us since any
hydrogen as you can see there is a a
more Dynamic right now approach to
hydrogen why because something has been
put into that Ira that helps that market
to actually become real so anything that
is supporting investment in Networks
you know great modernization resiliency
I think that's in the right direction
also the support for local content in
this global economy I think that's
positive helps a lot from a labor point
of view and other Dynamics so the
combination of these examples of laws I
think that might what makes right now
that the US one of the places everybody
wants to invest because you have
government at the federal understandable
state level taking decisions you have
money coming and helping when there is a
crisis and you have a Clear Vision that
at least you have 10 years of
predictability from a regulatory and
remuneration point of view I think those
are very good news so that is certainly
positive given some of the challenges
that you've outlined can you give us any
sense of the scale of the queue
for interconnection in the United States
at the moment and how rapidly or not is
rising right now there is a cure of
renewable projects of 1.7 terawatts
that's huge that's a cue that is 28 or
30 more than last year but to give a
simple number that is seven times the
current install capacity of Renewables
in the US which is 230 gigawatts so when
you have a queue of seven times the
install capacity I think that gives you
a feeling of how massive that renewable
energy is holding there to happen
incredible when you see the size of that
queue and and as you say that it is
growing year over year now
what should be done do you think in the
permitting uh process should there be
should this be a federal
um uh Power that can be held over States
you know how difficult that is going to
ever be what is the way to solve
some of these challenges this permitting
challenge in particular
I think the first action that any
government especially the federal
government but also the state government
is a streamline the process it depends
on you so you can actually take actions
so their own permitting or permits that
you take care of
the second one is every time there is
all these negotiations of new
legislations Etc I think it helps the
parties putting this back on the table
because that will allow for further
negotiation and further Improvement the
more we have a centralized decision
making the better I know you have a
state Dynamics you have Federal Dynamics
but the more I think we can focus on
centralizing at the federal level the
more rapid things are going to be
approved and at the state level I think
New York is the example how very rapidly
a new legislation on these local
upgrades clcpa has been approved and
that's why
newer standards for permitting
centralized extreme line anything you
can do in those fronts I think is going
to be important because those periods of
times right now are very very long not
comparable to most of the other
countries where these assets are being
developed as well and that's why for me
the more things we can do in any front
the better this is obviously a lot about
partnership as you say there's uh the
role of the state federal level
politicians Regulators what about
private companies like yours Pedro like
Avon grid What role can you play in
ensuring that some of the solutions that
you've put forward there can actually
become real
I think our obligation and that's what
we do for business and that's why we get
paid for it's very simple we need to get
things done I I don't like when people
blame the politicians for the mess in
energy or the mess in other things let's
look at ourselves what we can do I think
in our casing I've been great to have
zero Assets in the U.S 15 years ago to
have more than 40 billion right now to
have a three year a plan with more than
20 billion of capital expenditure of
investment I think as I always say in
this world of very complex situations
and being the renewable
one of them and decarbonization carbon
neutrality to help the weather and the
climate globally let's look at what each
of us are doing at least for us in 15
years to be the third renewable player
in the US with almost 9 000 megawatts of
renewable energy of course at the dollar
level probably the first one you know
when with more than forty thousand
meowatts I think for me we need to do
more but I think we're doing things
and you can bring in global expertise
can't you it's the notion that some
solutions that work in other parts of
eBay stroller's business can work in
America
the answer is absolutely yes I think Ari
patroller you know for the past 25 years
you know with our chairman galantino
leading you know this transformation
unique transformation that we have done
I can tell you the Strategic plan that
we put together in 2001 that we started
mentioning Renewables very few people
like that you know we were not given any
credit I can tell you the opposition
from our competitors was I wanna I'm
gonna say 100 but very close to 100
everybody was against and that's that's
what makes a leader you know to to
change things and and it's not us it's
everybody I mean you see right now so
many organizations how many governments
but we need to continue focusing on real
targets you know one of the things we
usually like is to focus on on 23 on 25
because that's what we have to do 20 30.
you know 2040 2050 that's nice goals but
let's focus on this on the short period
ahead of us and let's prove as many
things as we can do so to make those
changes when you are in at the Patrona
level not only financially but also you
know from an excuse point of view we're
doing officer right now in three four
five countries we're doing also winning
solar pick up the number 10 20 countries
I think anything going on in networks I
think we're always at the edge from a
technology point of view seems to me
that is is not only an honor to be part
of the patrol I think it's a must that
companies
behave on This Global approach because
this is the only way to pick up the best
from everywhere and try to apply in
other places let's move on to consumers
such an important part of this whole
um conversation how is the energy
transition in the US how does it benefit
uh consumers obviously
we've seen already as you say the
effects of catastrophic climate change
we're seeing that every day all around
the world
beyond that what are the advantages for
consumers how does the conversation work
so that consumers can really see the
value beyond that climate challenge
I think the first always obligation is
to prove that you create jobs you know
whatever you do I think in our case you
look at networks you look at our
renewable business poorly direct and
indirect jobs created in this period of
time that we've been doing business in
the US it's probably 70 000 U.S jobs I
think that's a massive number of new
jobs that in our absence would not be
here today
when you think about our investments
again 40 billion in 15 years seems to me
a very sizable number think about the
economic development
consequences of of those billions of
dollars
another example for me is purchasing we
are very keen Arab and great at the
group level and withdrawala to do
purchasing as much as we can locally
we believe that's an obligation if you
think about us as an example 2022 we did
almost 3.5 billion of purchases
in the US in our U.S business 94 of that
was done through local companies that's
where you see direct jobs in direct jobs
Economic Development everything being
put together when people speak about the
local content very important to get some
additional tax credits Etc I think in
our case we can prove it because when
you have you know almost 95 percent of
their purchases already being done
locally I think that is a must and that
shows how we committed we are locally
and then just looking at the company as
well you have focused the bulk of your
work on transmission and distribution
networks I know you've mentioned some of
the renewable energy generation you are
doing but your focus has been on
transmission and distribution just ex
take us through that why that has been
the focus for you rather than other
parts of the energy Network I I think
this goes to a vision that I think the
chairman and some of us with him you
know put on the table many years ago and
basically we decided to focus mainly on
networks and Renewables
both are needed and they need each other
you cannot build networks look at the
numbers we were mentioning before pick
up a thousand mail watt or 10 000 or 100
you know thousand you any number as you
know is happening right now well think
about that being put into operation
without any investments in networks it's
impossible but the other way around
consumers more energy and more and more
and more all the devices we use all the
time is more energy well you cannot
continue having obsolete networks are
not being upgraded that's why I think
the networks and Renewables the story we
thought it was clear since 2001 that
that was the they now come back
future and we have been proven to be
right and there is so much to be done
ahead of us that we're just almost
starting I know there has been a lot of
things that successfully has been done
to change the world but now you still
have pressure you know because there is
a war there is supply chain issues there
are many different Dynamics in the world
and those really are good and sometimes
things get a seen a little bit slower
that we all want but we need to continue
on making sure there is no stop now
Pedro take us forward
maybe maybe 10 years
you've taken us back to 2001 and when
you first started as a business making
significant noise in this area and
saying and outlining the
challenges ahead which as you say so
many of which have come to pass and come
true
10 years into the future looking back
what hope do you have for Avenger's role
and what the US grid should look like if
we do move at the pace you're calling
for with the right type of Partnerships
I think in our case again the numbers I
gave you around 21 billion investment
that we announced last year for for the
following three years that gives you the
big commitment part of that is also the
acquisition of electric distribution
utility in New Mexico but I think that
gives you the feeling of how committed
we are for the future in terms of
investment both in networks and
Renewables
I think we're very focused right now on
anything related to modernization and
digitalization is a must Smart Meters
let me give you an example we are
putting right now 1.8 million in New
York alone in 2025 I think we believe we
will have at least not 95 of all our
mirror being a smart meters that's a
huge change I know probably this should
have been done 30 years ago but you know
finally we're getting this done I think
now other areas of focus for us is asset
renewal I gave you the example of New
York there's nothing wrong it's just you
know very obsolete there's a huge
investment for those assets to be
renewed automation we need to make sure
that you know we target for example in
our opinion 75 of all our substations by
2025. that's a massive change versus you
know what we had very few years ago
Advanced data analytics I know this is
going on right now in almost any field
you can think of in our case for our
operations customer service is going to
be a must and finally
both home and they call it certification
we need to support it you know we
believe there is no comeback there may
be some slowing process you know
sometimes for different reasons but we
believe that's important in our case as
you know we are trying to contribute and
that's why when you ask me you know how
we're going to be 10 years from now I
would say look at our contribution right
now you know sure trying to help
Massachusetts massive investment think
about our transmission line from Canada
into Massachusetts massive investment
but massive help think about the 24
states where we are doing renewable
business in the U.S I think very few
people have that exposure and that
footprint into the whole U.S so we have
done a lot of things but I would love to
make sure that 10 years from now
electrification more Renewables more
networks has been the answer and
basically
the success in the years to come and
just finally Pedro you spoke a little
earlier in our conversation about some
of the hurdles and you spoke about the
Legacy companies
and some of the opponents that you faced
for example in different territories you
work in where you want to do work in
improving the transmission around
Renewables hydroelectric power for
example
what are the opponents doing and what
have you come across is this the old
fossil fuel companies as some people
might describe them that are that are
trying to as you say keep the market in
an Old State which frankly it did rather
well out of
what are the problems there that you're
facing first messages is normal you know
when you have a status law you are
earning and making nice money you want
things not to change so from that point
of view nothing is strange and that's
the world you know almost in any
business as you can imagine but that
translates into opposition promoting
patch hiring lawyers going into
litigation because I always say every
quarter you get something delayed you
still continue making a lot of money so
from that point of view I think this
opposition from field companies we have
suffered that in May I think you see the
Dynamics in some other places it's a
fact citing very important I think we
always feel like yes but but not in my
backtrack okay it has to be somewhere
else as we always say
the need of energy is there so if you
want to consume an energy you need to
make sure you produce it and you bring
it to where the consumption is
litigation as you can you have seen in
our case and many others it's an abuse
it's just you know using the legal
framework to just oppose something that
you know in many many cases you know
it's not going to be successful but you
get one or two year delay and again that
allows a lot of people to continue
making nice money and finally I think we
commented on this before permitting to
make sure that you know the bottlenecks
and the permitting process at the
federal state level is a streamlined
optimized centralized
etc etc I think it's also a must you
know and I think there are good progress
at the state federal level in that
direction and we are trying to help as
much as we can to put the parties
together and to put everybody in the
same direction give me Pedro
an optimistic vision
of what 10 years could look like
I think optimistic for me is comparing
to my grandparents house in a Country
Village in Spain when I was a kid that
in one of them there was no electricity
and in the other one I think I just
remember all the time the electricity
going off but also there were no toilets
you need to go and do that you know
somewhere else in the countryside I
think I think we're much better than 40
years ago so from that point of view you
know let's make sure we also see the
positive things right now but I think
when you see the climate when you see
the weather when you see those issues
you know globally right now in terms of
droughts hurricanes storms I think we
need to go faster because this world is
is only one we're enjoying this world
all of us but we need to make sure that
this world is not only for us it's for
many generations to come so if 10 years
from now five years from now I think all
these targets we have done 100 of that
or 50 of that or 200 of that that's what
I think will continue to make happy to
many of them of course in a profitable
way in a friendly way with you know you
know with environment you know trying to
bother us these people as possible but
also as quick as possible a lot of
issues that you need to face but having
you know done so many things already if
we can continue to accelerate we believe
that that will be for all of us what we
will make us very happy and pleased and
our furniture at the next Generations
behind us I think they will probably say
thank you Pedro what a lovely note to
end on your grandparents story let's
hope that all of our grandchildren's
story will be as positive as some of the
solutions you've outlined in our podcast
today thank you so much uh for joining
us and thank you as well everybody for
listening to this episode of energized
it was produced and edited by Bella Sims
thank you very much bye-bye